[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
so
[Music]
this
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
already already starting stuff man we'll
be starting here soon
[Music]
so
[Music]
this
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right
what's going on guys so we here playing
some uh
uh some chivalry too
uh
king's admiring the uh the demon suit
it's very lordly
[Laughter]
oh that's for the halloween yeah
oh somebody got the reverb yeah i was
making sure we sounded fine on my phone
uh oh how are you good because you can't
you can't you can't you can't trust the
chat sometimes they'll literally go the
whole podcast without telling you i'm
like oh yeah
there was some audio messed up but we
was okay we was okay stupid
oh i never i never said the
[Laughter]
what king says no
it created a monster you know
yeah
started with how are you just going to
start you tell us what boobies we do
when we started streaming we was going
to play start playing i was just doing
the team the team
i was just doing the team mode
just the the last team
that's the one we usually play isn't it
yeah but we gotta try after this we got
halloween
the new mode the fisticuff
the physical
it's delicious right yeah see because
you make it with love when you when you
make drinks with love they definitely
get crazy yeah don't tell me nobody's
playing every
[Laughter]
make sure your cross play setting is on
that's why
we want to play
oh we connected we should do
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
you're gonna be
right
yes
yo at the end there is literally 14 on
2.
i don't care
nothing they got that
[Music]
let's watch
let's go
cheeks
[Laughter]
he's trying to run down on me
okay
there's like eight of them you oh i just
i totally just
they jump at me son
i got killed
they're coming after me
someone protects me
scroll down protect me
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't forget the [ __ ]
oh and then you got the big
yeah watch out watch out oh watch out
watch out back it up back it up get up
get him while he's down that's right
that's right
i got killed a pumpkin
[Laughter]
oh
someone said sony players took down
added with the quickness
all right i'm gonna go over that kick
slash solve b software this i saw me you
go to the other side go downstairs
yo he says
oh
down
people
[Music]
yo there's a lot of them it's a little
bit of us yeah
[Music]
oh
get off my mess
oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that killing is so fast
[Music]
we let the pawns die first let them let
them
let them make it fire don't get there
it's just true
yeah
i would kick back hey let's go let's go
now we can seize them up there we go
somebody was stabbing me from the back
whoo
yo
crazy
dude is crazy
i feel right he's crazy yo
i need a sword though i gotta give her
this halloween
oh
[Laughter]
that didn't feel right that didn't feel
right oh he took his shield off and
started punching him in the mouth
ain't gonna be doing that to me like
that man yeah we gotta do the storyboard
after this i gotta i don't like that
i'ma stay on my side this team this side
i'm gonna stay on this side what's up
i'm gonna stay over here all right
yeah we stay over here
i'm going up here getting this dude
cause you ain't gonna be getting the
high ground on us all the damn time
i'm outta here
[Laughter]
this is disgusting
hey pumpkin head let's go
he don't kill four people i don't watch
them all oh my god he's coming he's
coming from behind oh he got this man oh
my god
this is jason jason
he chased that boy
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
i know
drunk
i want to get a win man
they got killers out there
for the win
i'm trying i'm trying to pad my record
man i'm trying to get the wicks man
that's the only one that was awesome
sixty-four play mix yeah six four player
mixtures
right now um
available
available for selection with for the
next octopus okay after this one we do
that at the that's the new mode that
they uh
imported
i don't know how i feel about going in
there
with my fists man delicious i wasn't
doing very well with an axe
you want me to do this
you
the siege of rooted heaven
i need that song read the text
hold on a second
let me get my england on yeah
let's go oh i got a halibut
all right let's go all right please push
to seize towers brothers
kill the pumpkin head get that pumpkin
hey
hold up i'm going around
i can't remember how you hail either i
can't remember nothing about it
oh my god come on how you doing
oh my god i forgot about the kick
i forgot about the kick i forgot all
that like
we have to play this in forever
oh it
all right saw me down
damn down what's up
what's up what's up what's up what's up
what's up i'm on the season come on
oh he threw him
and a dagger at me
we got to grab one of them joints the
armbar i'm grabbing i'm grabbing that
jordan you got to go
up the ladder
yeah we got to push this tower up you
got to stay there oh my god
blow the horns
oh yeah they'll do that
oh my god
shout out to the five dollar super chat
from
zg07 sees them they want you to say
oh
oh my god
seize them
oh they said they could test it
remember brothers
your life depends on the siege tower
somebody put something on my knee
go go into the uh
go to the very top go to the top go to
the top
i'm coming go to the top tap
ah let's punish
i'm coming i'm coming i'm coming
i'm coming
oh he definitely got me i got killed by
uber
i got it we got we got him we got him no
there's like three or four coming out
push that siege tower
oh they jumping there
oh my god
yo shout out to watch out man seven g7
fought out to the chest
i already ready
keep pushing
one of the siege towers shall reach the
other side we shall reach their defenses
i need to go to the tutorial
there's no way you should be killing the
king like that
capture the wall
capture the wall
face victim
their
yes yes brother come up here
thank you
[Laughter]
brother
capture the gatehouse brother he's going
to hit
[Music]
[Laughter]
damn it i have unlimited
capture
oh this dude right here man stop banging
me like that pause
oh get this dude
from behind oh
oh it's real i don't know i think the
[ __ ] head dude
i don't know where you're at
you got to get
the ladder
yo
[Laughter]
i guess the humility factor they gotta
have when we're in the pumpkin head we
got it so we got it i had nothing to do
with that jump that dude oh my god i
fell in love oh they're upstairs
[Music]
did you fall in the trap door
oh yeah
[Music]
sorry i got a crazy
i will not be cross playing on x get
yourself a [ __ ] feather oh damn
my man pumpkin fellow
[Laughter]
how come he got a shield and now i got a
shield i'm just running out of this
aliber addict why are you going up that
one
are you going up there oh they're
busting the tower down they're busting
the tower down i'm going to the left get
to the empty house i had i had no
success over there i see you guys over
there who's that cognito yeah i'm going
home yeah
over there go see where that little flag
is at yeah i'm watching you i was trying
to get that from the other side where i
jesus
i'm rolling with my man prometheus
jesus
oh who is that man
he's on fire man on fire
he has to do denzel yeah
i don't know what
i died by fire
[Applause]
let's go let's go
get this pumpkin dude
don't worry about that watch that go
straight to that second floor
i'm trying to get to the second floor
man
it's mad pumpkin dudes up here oh good
god
the whole team is jumping
[Music]
hard and evil
upstairs upstairs
what's the second brother
stab him
stab him
[Music]
why can't you stab him why
[Applause]
that
this is not going as planned and i think
attic has us on
regurgitate you know you know
you know this is against people right
it's not against
this is a lot of people yes
yeah
oh there you go
are you good
i'm not gonna lie these dudes definitely
defended everything they owned
we seized the castle but we did not
capture the stronghold brother
shout out to the dude that defended the
house
you
and this is worthy a drink to you my
friend
in hell
so you got to narrate the next part of
the story
what's up nova infinity this is on the
series x
[Music]
saturday night bubble up get it right
saturday night
i'm on that mom
yeah who do you think is playing this on
a saturday night but people didn't know
what they're doing
we're the only idiots out here i don't
know
that was a ps5 body
yeah
kill the arches
kill them
oh
oh jesus christ
yo these guys right here haven't studied
the ways of the force
oh
i'm done with this damn halliburg what
the hell you gotta switch when you die
you can switch off i think you just
switch off when you die
remember look at your green like don't
don't push too much with if you're
already losing the engagement
on god these dudes is wrecking me sir
this is what happens when you play
destiny too much
let us go
shout out to everybody
diversify their portfolio
and ain't doing like this
they want you to say
seize them knees king
knees
he's like me sir
the knees brother
kill off
[Applause]
[Laughter]
side
give me i got that man
sorry
too overzealous
right here i could curse what the hell
was this
oh
yes
sorry i've been chopping my teammates we
got to take team damage off
[Music]
what dude
yo that dude hit me in the chest with
fire my screen is bursting i'm dead
oh
yes you pumpkin dude i'm recording you
that's for the team
can't stand you
[Music]
oh
nick said king looking for aim assist
i'm looking for any assist if you're in
the game
brothers
why are you in the time you ain't
playing you got a chance to play with
the crew because you see the flag stand
next to stand next to your batter
[Music]
here we go there we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
yo what's my stuff is we need to jump
the king because at no point in time
should we be doing this for sports
[Music]
oh
oh
yo he lodged an axe in my head it's
still in my head while i'm walking
around that's hilarious
god that task oh they jumped me to
germany
somebody picked me
put both hands together put your hands
together
you ain't actively taking head i don't
know what you're doing paul jiggle
nice the red is falling push push push
push him push him
[Music]
get that dude
yo
kill those sneaky archers in the back
yes you will not dig my boy
your stuff away
yo how do i do okay i throw the oil part
by pressing down
jesus
this is the longest i've been up how do
i do oil pot
is it down what is it down
a user there you go but you gotta throw
it how you throw it
i think you throw it with um with both
uh left trigger right here guys
there you go
the music is changing brothers
is
those archers in the back man
it's the arches we gotta get the archers
i can't get to them i'm kidding
let's all push the let's push the left
side and get those archers
i'ma push to those arches anyway
we have only 30 troops left
sometimes
they said oh my god
those dudes over there they they're
swinging the mason son christian
pushing all the fathers and shut the
lord
[Laughter]
everybody
[Music]
they said no king you will give me thy
um
this is by far one of the hardest games
in the business
[Laughter]
i see why
we have not streameth this game earlier
this has not shown us in such a
oh
seeks to make a brutal example of the
peaceful village of copswell
no no no no i'm not fighting no place
called boxwell cox well
no no no four
[Laughter]
oh
why the
[Music]
hey stop standing close to me while i
bust the gate oh they got teammates son
[Laughter]
they're not as defenders that we thought
they got shields and stuff
we're in
with the home depot we have penetrated
the gate
oh
who am i going to hit with this rock i
made someone with this rock you want to
know someone is getting this right
i killed one of them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh oh that dude did the uppercut and
knocked me smooth out
disgusting
i'm behind you sovereign
i tell you this mortal i am like thanos
i am inevitable
i will seize thine oh
yeah village
yo he got a you got a battle cry that
says your mama
get this dude
[Applause]
i got killed by humongous look yeah
there we go
put the bonfire oh i got it i got it
that's the longest battleground it's the
longest battleground i've ever seen
i almost died if i ain't back up for my
teammates i learned
become one with thy block button
oh
oh i lost my helmet
oh my i lost my head
yo shut up you know what five minutes to
burn the city is almost
where are the women and children
oh my god why are you wearing that women
and children
[Music]
everything from
them spirit fights
yo hi you slaughter him like that
yes
yes i'm looking for that women and thy
children
[Applause]
don't go to the gate they're throwing
those
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
protect the rocks
protect the rocks
be good at pillaging later
made a good plate
i shall pillage that village
bust the gate
what are they doing to the gate
[Applause]
[Music]
oh god in them i thought fire
is killed
i give thee fire
give me my sword
steer the god
[Music]
[Music]
someone someone popped out in front of
me and i killed one of our peoples
it was an accident i didn't mean to kill
him oh you got him
my brother
treachery
treachery
[Music]
[Applause]
jesus man
i'm gonna give a shout out to snoop dogg
for sending me that bottle of uh
99 crooks
i got you killed the bird come crazy
pick up the crate
oh this is the furnace but i was still
oh he hit him in the head get over that
wall
oh
oh i hit him in the head with a barrel
[Music]
everyone go to the right one the far
right one we need to get right go right
let's just pillage let's go individually
let's pillage them together let's not do
it individually
we got a gang pillage
yes
page correctly
if
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i can assure you that is not an
objective right now
that is the objective of the game
i'm capturing dilute oh delicious
i'm capturing more loot
oh somebody help me on my back that's
all right put your paws on the king's
goal
all we care about
we must desecrate that goal
lot of them there's a lot there's a lot
he tried to hold down that bank on the
right side go to the left side
left side of this listen
change objectives if the right side
don't work
on the left atm
[Music]
behind you brother yo they run it out
with the goal of their head yo you see
that
there's just so many of them
he said the town is almost completely
looted
[Music]
keep it
pushing which side you go out of the
body i'm going to the middle because it
looks like it's empty
no but that's protect remember we got a
pillage got a steal
[Music]
[Applause]
all right it looks like the middle is
done so they abandoned him yeah no it's
still the pillage icon on the right or
the left
which one we doing i'm going to the left
oh my god
that sounds like i'm going to the right
oh my battery fell out i had my mic
the king was quiet for a second and yet
i am back i was saying hella reckless
stuff
oh
oh you got to take it out oh
you gotta literally take the gold and
run
it's hard to like pick it up man like
yeah the objective won't pick it up
because
the dumbasses put the emo button with
the what the button you push big stuff
up with
yeah so like when you try to pick stuff
up
you're trying to emote
yeah yes because it's the same button
yeah they got to fix that i agree
oh that's got the axe you run it with
the axe
now into the castle gates
yes yes
now when you get the gold where you got
to run with it i don't know i don't know
i had to go over my hand and i didn't
know where to run i ain't going to run
with it
just go back to the beginning
go back to the beginning
all right
we got one more minute
the gold is almost looted
thank you snoop dogg
what is this babe 99 criminals
what's up right
shout out to diddy for sending over
that's a rock
salute appreciate you god bless oh
there's only i think it's only on the uh
oh they're taking like eight years
oh stop them don't let them attack it
i got more gold
it dropped in the middle in the middle
in the middle in the middle oh okay okay
okay
y'all running out i'm running with the
booty
we don't need much more we don't need
much more dinner
put it in the truck yeah
we don't need much more
[Applause]
changing
we got it
on everything so this was a successful
stream yeah
[Laughter]
all right let's knock people out let's
get out of here
i had to wait for it to load remember
yeah
she done did it again another banger
another triple a banger
she had another aaa banger over here
exclusive
she's out here son they're right
they got that dude on the cross with the
pumpkin head what is going on in this
game
what is going on
well they picked them to the stake i'm
done you said the invite yeah yeah yeah
there you go all right
i took your invite
well hold on let me get that invite
cause they just took me someplace
and then we're
[Music]
don't get to see us
i can't just constantly go to people to
see that they're there
yo what is this
what
what is that
feast huh
octopus
[Applause]
[Music]
who interrupts my feast
for themselves yeah
i just got knocked out by fuzzy
fuzzballs
oh god biscuit monkey
i'm done
always dumb dude get to do the chat
oh you want a jumper dude
why you want to jump me it's every man
for himself
no i don't know if he's very bad for
himself the dude i think it is i think
it is opposite feet i'm just swinging on
dudes yeah the ones with the green and
the yellow with us
okay they could have picked most
distinctive colors yeah
clearly don't know
you know i will
um
[Music]
last one for the railroad well let's go
for the road why did it sound like that
what's going on
i'm drinking the berry
what is that guy looking at you funny
the brawl in the great hall
brawl in the great hall
when you drink too many leblanc
[Laughter]
[Music]
get him hit him hit him get him get him
hit him at him
what's going on why can't i move
they should not have gave that dude a
chair that was ridiculous
the octopus tastes delicious
can i beat you up
oh my god
you got it
616
the dress around at my amount of spicy
and sweet
i feel sorry for whoever's eating
regular food tonight
yo i swear y'all see the pictures and
y'all be like yo
delicious
i'm
[Music]
[Music]
too real over there
right in front of him
oh man that [ __ ] hit my chest
hmm
no who's swinging that slap shake why my
mig
they violent
ain't violent with it
your attic why are you a foreign
i can't see nothing right now baby i'm
busting a pumpkin head what
oh
you
he knocked him out with the tco you can
find on the floor on the corner
you got to demand more from your wives
telling you right now
if you ain't demanding more and i'm not
demanding nothing this boo boo love me i
love
i
her
shout out to the wedding next year
oh god invited to watch it
oh my god i gotta get a little bit here
you sitting down
yeah you have to get off yeah what is
with that oh that dude snot fox rocked
me son
i had to chill he he punched in between
the chair and snot boxed rocky
five kills to victory
yo
yo
all right get us out of here this is
ridiculous
[Music]
they try to keep that limited engagement
by that letting you
so so there you guys go
there there's your chivalry stream i'm
gonna go and end the stream
i'm ending the stream you guys have
anything to say
yo thank you everybody
to let y'all know we do play games and
this game is spitting up the lords it's
a fantastic it's a fantastic yeah
it's fun with your friends this is
absolutely listen
absolutely
anybody um please be safe for halloween
if you want out to parties tonight um
make sure you be safe and if you are
eating candy and getting it from uh
third parties
make sure you didn't get it from bill
cosby
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right all right
all right
so
there's your shimmery stream
there's your shimmery street i'm curious
like put it put it put in the put in the
chat real quick
put in the chat
put put in the chat real quick
the next game that you guys want to see
the lord's play on our next video
you talking to the stream yeah yeah i'm
talking to the stream
yeah i'm talking to the stream uh put
put in the chat i'm not saying when a
jackal landed on my head all right
i'm kind of curious you get a little bit
of feedback you're not guaranteed
to get that game but we definitely want
to give you guys a voice this is
delicious
we tried to
oh my i don't know it was the martini
that sparked it
but this right here
all right but definitely put in the chat
you guys uh i'll ask again
i'll ask again on the stream tomorrow
you guys have a good day